Now this asks fight, um, you're, you're
fighting him in July. That what does that,
July 6th? Yes sir. Um,
when do you like how much of
a camp do you give yourself?
How much of like a fully dedicated,
just all in camp, all day.
Every day. All Day. Every day. If
you look at them from a skillset,
Ben's not even worth waking up
before like 10:00 AM in the morning,
but I don't like to shoot man, before
my alarm goes off, I'm already awake.
I want to break his fucking face,
man on a break,
his fucking rib cage and I don't want
to knock them out early on and on.
I just want to hurt
towards you. That guy, man,
if I get the chance to torture him 14
minutes and 50 seconds before I stop him,
that's what I'm going to do, man. You
know, I just, I don't like to dude at our,
met him a long time ago. He's a
fucking prick man. I don't like them.
There's not too many people
that I generally dislike.
He's one of them. You know,
if I was a senior right now,
probably wouldn't be too
friendly of a greeting, you know,
now do you base this on how he talks
shit and just plays around and tries to
hype things up? Or if you had a
like a real conversation with them,
combination and things, you
know, uh, like, um, I'm the
type of dude that, um, if we,
if we train you go to
American top team Joe and say,
I get lucky and I tap you out twice.
I'm not going to ever tell nobody that
because I, that's not my glory moment.
That's just fucking training.
I don't give a fuck about that.
I already forgot about that.
But there's some people they violate
that man called Jim, you know,
I went to American top team, is it
like he's that type of pussy, you know,
and I go,
he's talking about Jim Storage and he
came over to American top team after I
dumped him on his head. We kept wrestling,
he got scrambled me and he said, yeah,
you beat me wrestling with,
we were straight wrestling,
two time national champion.
You're proud of that.
You're telling people that you know, and,
uh, it, that just shows me his character,
you know, he's not, he's
not who he pretends to be.
And then he talked so much online and
then I could have respected them a little
bit if he had held to his guns.
But I see him in London and as soon as
I see him, I start walking towards him.
He goes, hey man, uh,
I'm going to spare you.
I'm not going to say nothing
to after your fight, Ben.
Don't do me no fucking favors,
bro. You're not doing me no favors.
You say whatever the fuck you
want when you want it, you know?
And I dressed him and I went up to
talk to him and UFC got involved.
He put his head down and they escorted
him out of the hotel and he never came
back to that hotel,
you know?
And he actually wished me good luck at
some point too, like right before, like,
why are you doing this, man?
You're not that person on, on,
on social media that you portray to
be. You're not, you know, so you're,
you're fake as fuck.
You're sending something to the
public that is not there obviously,
and you're a coward. Fuck it.
Let's throw that in there too.
And if people don't believe me,
tune in July six I'll show you what,
how much of a coward he is.
Just to play devil's advocate,
don't you think that what he's doing
is smart marketing to play devil?
I know you don't like it. I know you don't
like it, but to play devil's advocate,
but it's corny though.
I when he looks
back, it's Corny. Like
ain't nobody going, oh,
he just wants validation.
He wants to be accepted.
I think half of what he's doing is corny
on purpose. All that. Boom roasted shit.
Come on, man. Half that stuff is corny
on purpose. No, no, no. That guy,
you haven't seen him and you
haven't hung around with that guys.
Just fucking pony. It's in his DNA.
I like him. I liked talking to him.
He's a smart motherfucker. Might be
smart man, but he's a motherfucker bro.
And he's this cocky for all the
wrong reasons. I just can't wait.
I love the fact that you're a purist
like this though. I really do.
I want to hurt that.
I know you do that.
When I heard that it's going
to be a great fight. It's,
it's one of those interesting fights
because you've got good wrestling,
takedown defense. You've got very
good wrestling. You've got a good,
very good takedowns yourself, but you
clearly have a big advantage and striking.
Yes, so it's one of those, Ken, he
imposes will. Can I get ahold of you?
You want to get ahold
of these fucking nuts?
Yes ma'am.
Which we will talk to
you to me in the past,
but they'll say to my face
and minute gained respect
for. Right. Cool Bro. I'm a,
I'm a punk or whatever you call. You
said it to my fucking face. You know,
but you say it online.
It's just the whole way it gets
said about you say it online.
Then when you see me, what's up? Hey,
how are you? Ain't man picture picture.
I fucking kidding me
man. Fuck. Is it weird?
I feel like I've been brought up from
like a twilight zone from a different
dimension.
Sometimes.
There's a lot of these rappers fighters
that you see acting like criminals on,
on the social media when they
see me. Hey, what's up bro?
Let me get a picture at all.
Fucking fanboyed out. Oh Man.
Could have sworn you were just
mentioning my name. Seen some shit, bro.
That's fucking nuts to me.
[inaudible] my mind. Right?
I'm such a simpleton. Roy just blows
my mind every time. You're a purist.
I don't know if it's appears symbol.
I don't know where you want to put me,
but it's not simple to mind.
Just don't want to play that game.
You're not interested in that
game. It's mine. Yeah. Listen.
Khabib's on it shouldn't have fucking
game either, but he's on top of Connor.
Let's talk now. Bam. Let's talk. Yeah,
come on. Let's talk. Let's talk. Now.
I notice the same shit
purist. I love it. I do.
I appreciate when that shit
talking has consequences. Yeah.
I like some shit talking though. It's
fun. I starting when you back it up.
Yeah. Back that shit up. Yeah.
Now you see me in a hallway lobbying
fucking run to security and get escorted
down. Who's the guy you fought in the
past you had the most beef with before you
actually fought?
Uh,
I don't know. I never really had like
real meat. No. So not like this fight,
like telling you went back and forth
a little bit, right? No, no, no, no.
We went back and forth like,
Hey, you want to fight? Yeah,
let's do it. Fuck it. Boom,
boom, boom. But we never will.
It's pretty respectful. Yeah. Yeah.
To his occluded with man. What
about cowboy? Cowboy? I mean, yeah,
a little bit of beef. You know, that's in
crazy, like if I see him in the street,
we're going to start fucking
fighting or nothing. You know?
Is that what you mean by like beef for
just like we're going back and forth
talking shit to each other like, yeah,
me cowboy. Sure. You write me cowboy.
We're talking a lot of shit back and
forth to town, you know? Yeah, yeah.
He's coming from genuine places,
from both sides, you know?
So it was good and made it,
gave that fire, you know?
Yeah, that's definitely one.
It came from like a little bit of
hostility. Not like this. Ask in one.
I respect cab. We're going into that
fight. You know, obviously he's,
I think he's a fucking stud. Boon. He
proves it again by having the most wins,
most knockouts, submissions,
dude's a stud. I,
I don't think astrons even yet to
get a win in the UFC. You know,
I just think about it like if
I had fought Robbie Lawler,
which was a great champion and has done
amazing things in the sports and the
start of Robbie turnout by
like I still fighting man.
I remember watching him in
the UFC back back in the day.
[inaudible] seven and a
half with the fuck guy.
He came along and the half dude fucking
lean people stuck out and it looked
amazing. It looks, yeah,
looked fucking amazing.
Looks amazing physically when
he hoisted asking up the errand,
dumped him on his head and then started
just driving his fucking knuckles
through his brain.
And it shows you how tough asking is.
The dude's durable is fucked man.
He handled that.
He's built for survival
even by his body type.
You get told like physiologically he's
just built for a guy like me to put them
under the rate of like, oh, this guy's
not a threat. Look at him, you know,
but it's not going to work.
I already know what to do to this
guy and just fucking hurt him man.
Even the way he's
fucking buildings for it.
Patheticness let's skip the subject,
man. Let's go to somebody else. Man.
Make this guy famous on your show. Too
late, too late. Well this man will,
they put his picture up on the, on the
marquee. He gets a big pop. It's crazy.
People love aspirin. I, I guess, I don't
know. Haven't seen him. Loved him before.
He fought in the UFC too.
I had never seen that cause I,
I saw in England, in England, they
didn't fucking hated his ass man.
They were born him out
of the fucking stage
cause he looks like he belongs
there. Right? He looks like, ah,
you left us lad. He looks like
an English guy, doesn't he?
I guess man does not like a, what do you
do you think his nationality is aspirin?
He looks like he probably has
some English in him. Curly hair.
Want English dudes have
curly hair. Yeah, you got it.
[inaudible] who's got a
wild that's wrestling style,
wrestling style. It's funky.
Yeah, it's very unusual. Very effective.
You know he's going to have that
wrestling match with Jordan Burroughs.
She couldn't get smashed. Is that before
or after yours? I think used to be four.
Does that concern you or you
might get injured doing that.
I don't give a fuck if he does this
because he faked an injury out. You know,
he knows what he's doing.
He's a big boy. You know,
like if you're going to
fight Joe Romeo and uh,
one of your teammates might come up
to you and tell you like, hey man,
I think you should fake the injury
and the Drake what drove him?
I would just faked an injury and cop
out of that fight. You don't want no,
no problems with that guy, you know? So
that might be what he's trying to do.
Who knows?
Man.